hot glamorous elaborate and full of love
is how you could describe paris hilton's
wedding after parties which included a
private carnival a star-studded soiree
and more you know i'm not your
traditional bride after tying the knot
with hubby carter room in a lavish
ceremony on thursday in los angeles the
two continued the wedding festivities
into friday where they let loose at a
private carnival party on the santa
monica pier i'm so excited a source
tells e.t that the partygoers were
treated with famous carnival treats
including funnel cakes hot dogs on a
stick and dippin dots as for drinks they
served rose white wine personalized cans
of water and gave out shot glasses with
the couple's logo and of course it
wouldn't be a carnival party if it
didn't include games party guests wrote
the piers famous ferris wheel and played
a special paris-themed ring toss game
where they won pillows with you guessed
it paris's face on them
as for the big centerpiece paris enjoyed
an enormous barbie themed cake which
took five days to create speaking of
barbie the heiress was on brand rocking
a custom-made alice in olivia pink dress
with a matching mason avavelle as far as
a celeb guest demi lovato came to show
love so did gigi gorgeous and lance bass
the night also included a surprise dj
set from diplo that made the crowd go
out i'm just so blessed and i can't wait
for the next step in our life then on
saturday the couple went a little less
carnival and a little more couture for
an upscale star-studded black tie
reception paris looked breathtaking and
a curve-hugging semi-sheer silver dress
with star-shaped embellishments carter
looked dashing and classy in a black on
black suit my best friend and my
prince charming all rolled into one a
source tells e.t quote saturday's party
was bigger than thursday's event but
still intimate it was held at a gorgeous
estate and every type of food you could
imagine was there including caviar sushi
pasta and pizza the guest list included
paris family like her sister nikki mom
kathy and brother barron it's just
beautiful it really really is paris
celebs like sofia richie jaden smith and
kate beckinsale were also there the
entertainment for the night macy gray
who treated guests to a live performance
the singer also spent time hanging out
with the newlyweds
after the weekend long celebration the
couple is ready for some rest and
relaxation a source tells e.t quote
paris and carter are vacationing on
their honeymoon they are absolutely
exhausted from the weekend festivities
and barely have voices but they both had
the best time and the celebrations were
everything they could have asked for i'm
really excited to share that with all my
fans all three days of paris and
carter's lavish wedding celebrations
were captured as part of the heiress's
new peacock docu-series paris in love
which the 40 year old teased the e.t
before her big day well we just started
shooting our new show paris in love on
peacock and we're shooting in new york
just now actually
and getting ready for the dress fitting
and just planning the bachelorette party
and there's a lot so i'm i'm really
excited to share that with all my fans
does this mean the wedding is televised
yes
yes
[Music]
you